[Music]
yup that's me charles foster kane you're
probably wondering how i got here here's
a newsreel to get you up to speed
[Music]
suddenly a man steps in the frame and
points a gun at her this is not her day
fade to black
title
three weeks earlier
i'm fascinated with a specific kind of
opening scene it's not exactly a cold
open since it doesn't always happen
before the title sequence and it's not
just a tangential scene that establishes
the tone of a movie like the beginning
of indiana jones it's a particular cult
open that drops you in the middle of the
story without any context we lost doug
what
we can't find doug
the opening is so well known that it's
even become its own meme popularized by
robot chicken in 2010.
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa did you ever
have one of those moments where you
think how the hell did i get here since
this type of opening gets parodied so
often it might feel like a lazy
narrative choice i'm not a huge fan
personally of the whole three weeks
earlier teaser thing i feel like you
know we should start our stories where
they begin not start them where they get
interested but this supposed cliche is
also used in many critically acclaimed
stories from iconic tv dramas to
cinema's all-time classics even
ratatouille one of my favorite movies
replicates that classic meme almost
exactly
this is me so how can a seemingly tired
cliche also show up in so many stories
we love well it all started just a few
short millennia ago
movies and tv were not the first to skip
over parts of their stories the ancient
poem the odyssey begins at the end of
the trojan war so the reader starts
during odysseus's journey back home the
roman poet horus the video essayist of
his time described this choice as in
medius res translated to in the midst of
things making this kind of opening one
of the earliest identified tropes in
history and it seems to have caught on
like when hamlet starts after the king's
death skipping a core event and instead
starting with the appearance of the king
as a ghost so the opening i'm talking
about is a version of this ancient in
media's res we begin in the middle and
then rewind to show how the character
got there at its most basic this how i
got here trope adds mystery to a story
in many classic noir novels and movies
we start off seeing the character in a
crisis and it draws us into the plot
there's something exciting about
watching someone plan their heist
knowing that they will fail but not
knowing when or how in the first scene
of citizen kane we get a serious version
of this how i got here opening we
watched the death of the main character
charles foster kane the mystery of his
dying word rosebud drives the plot of
the story as we find out how he ended up
in a giant mansion all alone on the
comedic side a lot of animated movies
used this opening for laughs because of
the cold open in the emperor's new
groove we already know that cusco turns
into a llama so it's that much funnier
when he has his slow transformation at
the dinner table whether it's dramatic
or comedic the trope is a great way to
sprinkle irony into your story right
from the beginning we know something the
characters don't so talk to me about
vegas uh you know it should be pretty
mellow so when a cold open doesn't
provide that sense of irony it can feel
lazy the movie daredevil opens with him
falling on the floor seemingly close to
death but once we actually catch up to
that moment he just gets up and keeps
fighting not only does the cold open end
up feeling inconsequential but there's
also nothing really surprising about a
superhero getting a little beat up so
it's not much of a memorable hook to
begin with just showing something
climactic like someone near death or a
gun in their face isn't inherently
enough to make for a good how i got here
opening the moment should tease at
future narrative or character-driven
payoffs and this kind of opening is
often not necessary to begin with in
fact many movies work much better
without it mad max fury road starts with
a simple exposition then shows the rest
of the story in sequence that choice
lets the audience feel like max himself
constantly trapped in a never-ending
present danger with only split-second
flashbacks of past trauma although a mad
max cold open would be pretty funny
you see that guy right there that's me
you're probably wondering how i got into
this mess
jokes like that have become big on the
internet the formula is simple show a
precarious situation and add that famous
narration but the idea of telling
stories in this fashion extends far
beyond simple memes not only do many
movies and tv shows use this concept but
cold opens even get applied in areas
outside of media a research article
published in 2018 discusses applying the
cold's open to education it's the same
basic idea as starting a story in the
middle before the actual lesson teachers
first present a fresh problem to
students without any context and let
them try to work through it on their own
this technique helps introduce new ideas
because it forces the students to apply
existing knowledge and build on their
understanding as they enter the actual
lesson they can then better engage with
the material because they've already
established that introductory foundation
and they know what to look out for at
its core that's exactly how the how i
got here opening works in movies memes
or even dumb video essays the technique
forces the viewer to see something out
of context and create their own
associations with that new material by
forcing the viewer to build those
associations themselves when done well
cult opens make us more invested in
future character or narrative arcs and
they make the climactic payoffs more
emotionally satisfying that's why the
rosebud reveal in citizen kane ended up
so iconic and it's why the initial image
of walter white in his tidy whities made
his transformation into a gangster that
much more exciting the record scratch
meme pops up on the internet all the
time so the trope may feel inherently
cliche or lazy but i don't think that's
true at all we've craved the mystery and
excitement of the cult open for as long
as storytelling has existed and some of
the best movies in history use the
technique i think the trope has lasted
so long because it speaks to some innate
human curiosity we find joy in seeing
things without context moments that
force us to put the pieces together
ourselves whether that puzzle is an
iconic story or a quick joke so yeah
that's me praising stupid online memes
and comparing them to the intro of one
of the greatest movies of all time and
yes i am also wondering how i got here
if you liked the video hit the subscribe
button below and thanks to all my
patreon supporters for supporting this
video thanks for watching